[Music]
you
hello so
we are back today with a section on
attention and to start this session
we'll do a quick recap of what we did in
the last lecture and from there on we'll
continue with the today's lecture so in
the last lecture what we focused on or
what we did was we looked at what is
attention what does it really mean and
we also looked at the various factors
which control attention and the various
theories of what attention is so a quick
recap onto the concepts which we
discussed in the last class of attention
basically is filter it's a process or
it's a mechanism of the brain which lets
the brain control the kind of stimuli
which is impinging on to the brain from
the sensory organs and attention is very
beneficial because attention limits the
capacity of the mental resources which
should be diverted to various cognitive
processes which are taking place in the
brain
so basically attention is an important
factor now the question that we asked in
the last class was whether attention can
be increased or whether there is
something called diverted attention so
with practice whether we can use the
attention of capacity that we have on
different tasks and as an answer to that
we saw that as you practice more and
more what we get is that we can divert
our attention and this is called divided
attention we can use our resources
mental resources on several activities
so basically while doing one job we can
also put our attention onto other job
and this basically when we are able to
divide attention to several other jobs
to a number of jobs then some of the
jobs which are less important which are
routine becomes automatic and the ones
on which we are focusing attention
presently is the one which is at the
attentional system which is at the
center of attention another interesting
thing which we saw was that attention is
basically a mechanism with fluctuate so
attention basically keeps on fluctuating
from movement to movement there is
something called attention span which
basically defines for how long attention
would be put on to something or for how
long attention is being captured now in
addition to that we saw something called
selective attention base is basically
focusing our attention on to something
specific how do we focus our attentions
on two specific things and look into
specific things which is basically
equivalent took something called mental
conscious concentration in addition to
this we also looked at a couple of
theories so brief review of the theories
we looked at something called filter
theory which defines the fact that on
filter theory says that only those
processes only those stimuli which on
which we focus our attention to our
process and other stimulus are not
processed so our focus of attention
besides what stimuli gets processed and
what stimuli doesn't in addition to that
it also points out that some features of
the unprocessed stimuli are processed
but these are physical features and so
nothing of much value and so this there
was an experimentation then by Chery
using something called dichotic
listening task to prove how attention
should be studied later on and a
tradesmen went ahead and challenged the
filter theory why because Mori came up
with the idea of something called
cocktail what a phenomena and he was
able to show that some materials from
the unintended here or from and from
those processes should not attended to
could also pass for example somebody's
name and so Ana tradesmen came up and
gave her gave her theory of attenuation
theory which says that attention
basically what attention does it doesn't
filter out things but it attenuates or
volume downs
the material which is attended which is
unattended which we are not putting our
attention to and if needed we can
actually go ahead and process that in
addition to that we also looked at
something called the late selection
theory where we looked at the bottleneck
which was defined by the filter theory
which exists right at the beginning of
an incoming message nor shapes toward
the back of the message which basically
means that most messages goes ahead and
are processed for meaning for some level
of meaning not all level of meaning but
seven level of meaning and depending on
the kind of processing that that you
require kind of processing being
happening or the kind of differentiation
that you want the the place at which the
differentiation happens the messages are
processed what I mean by this is that at
what level two messages differ we'll
decide to what extent messages a process
so let's continue with our discussion
and focus on to our look into a new
theory of attention which is called the
multimodal theory of attention so it's a
very brief theory it's a very short
theory which was proposed by someone
called Johnston in Heinz in 1978 and it
is called the multimodal theory of
attention and what they say is attention
is actually a very flexible system which
allows for the selection of message over
others and this selection of message or
this filtration of message from the
incoming stimuli happens at three stages
so most of the messages pass through
stage 1 stage 2 stage 3 of processing if
the message is filtered at stage 1 it is
called early selection then a message is
filtered at stage 3 it is a late
selection now so how is this Theory
little bit different the only thing
which is different in this theory is the
variables which controls stage 1 or
which direct stage 1 stage 2 and stage 3
which basically describe stage 1 stage 2
and stage 3 and as you can see stage 1
is
sensory representations where the
sensory representation is constructed so
if a message is processed early on it is
processed at the level of the
representation with the messages
creating onto the neural structure so if
the representative itself and so
basically it will be physical properties
of the message which makes us apply that
racial filter or which directs the
attentional filter for processing here
if both the messages are a number of
messages are approaching us or the
incoming stimuli has a number of
messages different messages which are
very similar in terms of the physical
property then they can the more or less
have the same kind of representations so
how are they processed in this case the
message are differentiated the filter is
applied based on the semantic
representations of the message so at the
level of meaning so what this theory
goes ahead and says is that most
messages which differ so the first
factor which is used for processing
messages for separating messages by the
attentional filter happens at the level
of the physical stimulus or at the level
of the representation itself and as you
know that sensory representations are
generally the kind composed of the
physical features these are the first
features or these are the first
representations which are made onto the
brain or the mind now in the second step
if messages which are approached are of
more or less same kind a meaning wise
differentiation happens separation of
messages is done in terms of what the
meaning of the messages a fact where
most messages or two messages have the
same meaning or nearly same meaning and
they have the same kind of physical
features what happens then in those
cases are deeper level analysis a deeper
level of filtration a deeper level of
attentional processes really work and
here the separation or the filter is
dependent on both the semantic and
sensory representation
into takes takes care of or it takes
includes both the semantic
representation and other senses
representation so if most messages are
similar in terms of outwardly similar
physical features and semantics
semantics meaning then a third level of
analysis where happens it's a deeper
level of analysis is a deeper level of
filtration we're very very minutely
the sensory features are looked into and
the semantic features are looked into
and in combination the sensory features
and the semantic features are in
combination with each other then become
the basis or differentiation of two
messages so this is what the theory is
and this is a very simple theory of
Hines and Johnston the next theory that
we talked about is Daniel Kahneman
theory even before we go ahead and look
at Daniel's kind of a theory of how
attention really works let's talk about
attention then the capacity of
attentional systems and the mental
effort which is required for moving or
using attention so more psychologists
are actually looking at in terms of
attention those messages the factors
which make a message being processed or
what makes what factors of a message
makes something being processed and they
are not looking at those factors which
are not making a mess being processed to
make it more simple since in attentional
as in attentional theory or in terms of
an attentional experiment most
psychologists are now focusing on the
fact that what makes a message being
selected for processing so they are not
looking at those factors which which
makes a message not get processed but
they're looking at those factors which
make a message being processed and they
believe most psychologists nowadays
believe that looking at those factors
which basically give this idea of how
something is in process or what is the
way in
with something using process that should
be and that should be the the the center
of attention of attentional studies our
center of focus of attention certain
status now one particular experiment or
one particular view which defines how
attentional focus or what is the
capacity of attention is the viewpoint
of those theories which look as look at
attention as a spotlight so a group of
theorists believe that attention is like
a spotlight on a stage and so what is
this center of the stage is what focuses
attention and what they believe is that
most spotlights that that is there on a
stage or any particular area the
spotlights and fuzzy boundaries it
basically means that part of messages
which are towards the boundary of the
spotlight also gets processed now Daniel
can men he gave a very interesting
theory of attention where he used
something called things like a location
policy things like user disposition
things like physical states and so many
other things or so many other factors or
defining how attention the alliteration
filter really works or how the process
of attention really works and so what
Daniel Kahneman says is that attention
is a set of cognitive processes which is
used for categorizing and recognizing
stimulus so Kalman proposes a model
which views attention as cognitive
process which helps in making categories
in making categories of the incoming
stimulus or taking incoming stimulus and
assigning them into pre recognised
category and while doing this because
this helps in the recognition or in the
identification of the stimuli what he
believes is the more complex stimuli and
incoming stimuli is the more mental
resources is needed the lesser complex I
enter in an internal stream
an external stimuli is the lesser that
national resources are needed so
essentially this model then depicts the
location of mental resources to various
cognitive tasks
now if on the right hand side you
actually see the model itself of how
this canvas model really work now as if
let's decipher this model a little bit
and see how this model really works and
as you see what can man believes is that
there are a number of mysterious
determinants from in the environment
which decides whether a message is
processed or whether our message should
be processed or not and this
miscellaneous determinants are something
which is physical in nature and this
comprises the physical property of any
incoming messages but once a message
enters into or impinges on our sense
organs it is the level of arousal which
decides whether a particular message
will be will be attended to or not so
basically the first and important factor
in his theory Daniel Kahneman theory of
attention is the level of arousal and we
have seen this level of arousal also in
previous theories which says that level
of arousal is an important factor which
determines whether a message gets
processed or not and so what Daniel
Kahneman says is that with high levels
of alertness high levels of arousal a
chances of processing the chances of
attentional filter working is very high
also he says that not only the ll the
arousal levels but also the available
capacity how much capacity or how much
mental country the concentration is left
that defines how the filter will work if
a very less mental capacity is available
if most of the mental capacity is taken
up then the attentional filter will not
work as required and so as wanted but
then if the available capacity is high
and there also is less the filter works
perfectly or these are the terms on
the filter actually works and another
factor an interesting factor which
defines the functioning of the
attentional system or the attentional
filter is the evaluation of demands of
the capacity how much demand is being or
made on the attentional capacity if some
other job or most jobs which are
happening with the new incoming stimuli
which needs to be filtered are automatic
in nature is the the eval if the demand
on the attentional capacity or the
attentional resource is less then an
effective filter will work or the filter
working will be effective but if a
second job which is given to you or the
secondary job that you are doing in
addition to focusing your attention on
to something new what would really
happen is that both jobs will compete
with each other and lesser attention is
required and the chances are a filter
will block the new message or block the
important important contents of the
message also in addition to the arousal
in the available capacity the allocation
policy is important term for Daniel
Kahneman's theory now what is allocation
policy according to a Denman Daniel
Kahneman allocation policy in the model
is affected by individuals in enduring
dispositions and momentary intentions
and the evaluation of demanded mental
capacity so what he says is the the way
the kind of system that we use for
allocating or for distributing mental
concentration or mental effort on two
different tasks depends upon three
things one is the enduring disposition
it is like the interest so if a person
is interested in something he is bound
to put much attention to that particular
thing and want to put lesser attention
to other things so if somebody is doing
something interesting chances are that a
lot of his attention policy will be
allocated to that job and very less of
attention is
left over but if somebody is doing a
boarding job a job which which which is
not of interest to you and which is not
something which you endure it's not an
enduring disposition something not of
your liking what would happen is that
you would basically most of your
attention attentional system is
available resources are available and so
what would happen is that most of the
since it is available it can be it can
be made to use also of interest our
momentary intentions our momentary
intentions is things which happens at
the moment so at the time of processing
at the time of when attentional filter
really works when something is a new
stimuli comes in what happens then so if
if the task demands are something or if
at the time of processing and even to
occurs which requires you to focus
yourself on to something else when to
some some other event or some other job
or some other some other feature of a
stimuli and those reasons or those
things could be also responsible for our
allocation of how much allocation you
can do our mental resources to a
particular you even incoming stimuli and
so this how much demand is being made
how much of the processing is going on
presently what are your likes and
dislikes and water is a momentary
intention these these these factors will
define how a person will define or will
divide his attention so basically
looking at it the first factor which
basically decides whether attention
would be paid to something or not is
basically somebody's or a person's
arousal level and available capacity
well the person is aroused enough and
whether he has a huge or not if not huge
but a substantial amount of available
cognitive resources if the resources are
pre using something is being used in
something then the person will not
attend to any new messages or will not
at potential will not come into play
given the fact that the enough
attentional capacity is available and
illa Feroz 'el is there or more than
maximum level of arouse
seneschal capacities available even then
your attention onto a particular job
will depend on the allocation policy of
how things are being located and/or how
somebody wants to allocate that or how
somebody wants to put their attention
onto something and this will depend upon
your likeness and liking unlikeliness or
some things your motivations towards a
particular job or towards a particular
event which is happening at the present
also on what happens now so some sudden
event might occur which might take up a
lot of your attention so think of
yourself counting notes in in a bank or
people counting bank tellers counting
notes and a sudden loud bang comes in
now when a sudden loud bang comes in or
a sudden loud bang happens the it's very
difficult for the person who's doing
this job of counting the notes to focus
on to it and his attention will save so
momentary intentions are those things
which happen in the moment and so those
are those demands of those environmental
demands are those movement demands which
shift attention other thing of interest
are the evaluation of demands on the
available capacity so how much demand is
right now how much tasks are you doing
in addition to the present task which is
in hand and these will decide all
possible activities that somebody can
actually go ahead and do we all look a
location boss policies will decide how
much attention you will put to something
how much attention you're going to put
on to something else and this finally
will decide the responses so basically
this theory goes ahead and says that
attention depends not only on arousal
and available capacity it also depends
upon people's motivations liking and
likings momentary features and the
current demand on a particular current
demand on a particular system or on a
particular processing which at the next
theory that we look into is something
called
the schema theory of attention and so
this is a very interesting theory of
attention because this is our totally
a different view of attention and so
what this theory actually goes I didn't
says so this theory was first of all
proposed by someone called logic myself
in the year 1976 and this is called the
schema theory so what is the theory
actually goes ahead and says it's a very
interesting theory a very interesting
approach which says that people's
attention doesn't go ahead and filter or
unfilter something so people's attention
is not a process which actually
separates things which gets filtered
through it and something which doesn't
get filtered to it what he says is that
things which are not filtered things
which we won't put put our attention on
to we actually don't go ahead and
perceive it in any way so basically what
this theory says is that the schema
theory says is that only those things
which we focus our attention to uh
perceive but those things which we won't
focus our attention to are not perceived
at all it's not taken in at all and so
attentional system doesn't work like if
in in or if then kind of a system but it
works as all-or-none kind of a system so
if every so if attentional systems
basically decide if everything is
processing whatever is not processed is
left over and nothing no kind of even or
no kind of mental resources are
allocated to it
now what he says is that attention the
process of attention is more or less
like apple picking from trees it is like
picking messages from trees so when he
says that when we go apple picking think
about we go picking mangoes or apples
from trees the ones that we pick are the
ones which are available to us and the
ones that we don't see remain on the
tree and similar to that schema theory
basically says that the one message the
messages that we put our attention on to
are the only ones that we should be
interested in or that we care about the
ones that we do not look into that we do
not pay our attention to that will not
focus on to actually remain outside the
system and there are
or there are there is no way to
basically go ahead and process them to
prove that this kind of approach is true
that what we don't process or what we
are not being attention to is not
process at all to look at a system like
this nicer and blacken conducted an
experiment in 1975 to provide evidence
to this theory so it's a very simple
experiment which was done now there were
two different videos which were shown to
a group of subjects on the first video
you see people are hands slapping so
this is the first video in which you be
the subjects in the experiment saw
people hand slapping and they had to
count the number of hand slapping so
this is an easy job to do and people
were able to count the number of hand
slaps which were being made on the
second video people went ahead and saw
the number of ball passes which were
happening between people so there are
three people who are playing a ball and
a number of ball passes are happening
and so the job of the subject or the
person hosting taking part in the
experiment is to count the number of
passes which the ball is making from one
person to another or the number of hand
passes that is being happening so both
easy jobs to and so people were able to
do them a third video was made where
people were made to look into this video
and the sport from what this video had
is a superimposed image so put the
videos were superimposed on to one
another and so people were actually
asked to shadow one of these videos the
video that they had to shadow was the
one which is ball passing so now what
happened is a third video is presented
so in video one you count the number of
hand passes sorry the number of hand
slapping which is there in number two
you look at the number of ball passes
and in number three what you tend to do
is the soup in the superimposed video
you actually have to share
we actually have to read aloud or tell
aloud how many ball passes are there so
there are two images there are two
superimpose videos there on one you have
the hand stepping going on on the other
you have the ball passing going on and
so what really happens then is that
people are so as we forgot focus to put
their put their mind onto the hand
passes people don't really pay attention
to what is happening in the hand
slapping experiment and soon enough
if you're five minutes into the video
the people who are hand slapping
actually stop doing that and starting
passed and started passing balls to each
other but it people most people most
experimenters actually 80% of the people
who view this video we're not able to
recognize how this or when does this
switch happens they don't realize that
people who were doing this hand slapping
this changed to ball throwing this kind
of thing was not noticed and so this
video and even when the experiment ended
and a brief recap before view of the
video was overview of what this on the
video was taken 80 to 85 percent people
are not able to tell whether this hand
slapping video in the hand slapping
video the change happened in terms of
people stopped hand slapping and started
throwing balls which basically provides
evidence to the fact that that attention
could be a system which is and if and
and all or non kind of a system where
what you perceive is what you perceive
and what you don't perceive actually
doesn't get into the system at all now
similar to the study done by a nicer and
back pain an interesting fact which is
of this or which is present in our
environment is something called
inattentional blindness no inattentional
blindness is basically a phenomena where
things in front of us we don't see it
now often the most of you would have had
a scenario in which I think you are
looking for is just in front of you and
you don't
it and this particular phenomena is
called inattentional blindness and this
is basically even if something is in
front of you you don't see it and so
this provides inattentional blindness
provides support to the schema theory so
to study in attentional blindness to
kind of experiments were done in one
experiments people were passing ball
among each others and so there were 40
hand passes of ball which were there at
the rate of 40 hand passes per minute
and so most subjects we're advice to
actually go ahead and count the number
of hand passes and so people actually
endorsed onto that and so they looked at
the number of hand passes which
happening to look at we do this and we
do this and so in this week people look
at a number of hand passes which are
actually going along and then very
equally or very nicely they're able to
count the number of passes that the ball
made from one object to another
no hidden from the subjects attention
where two events which most subjects
actually didn't notice only twenty
percent twenty five twenty five percent
people actually went ahead and knew that
this happened this even happened so
within this scenario of ball passing in
one case a person carrying an umbrella
came in between these ball passes or
came in so look at this person this
person I'm talking to he came in between
and he passed these people whose hand
passing similarly in one case a woman a
short woman wearing the dress of a bear
came in and passed this particular thing
so if you want you can actually go ahead
and see this video of inattentional
blindness it's available on YouTube and
you can see that when engorged when
somebody is engorged onto a job and when
it a difficult job like this example how
many hand passes are being taken placed
count the number of males who are
passing the ball and Contin umber of
females from
whom the ball is passing and if this
kind of task load is put onto your
attentional system is put on to your
processing system what happens is people
are not able to focus on on stimuli
which is just in front of them as you
see that these two stimuli these two
people are the bear clad lady and here
the umbrella taking man passed in front
of people's eye but they were not able
to recognize this they were not able to
see this the reason is that as more and
more load our pole is put into the
attentional system you do not process
things in front of you
we basically suppose a partly a schema
theory that what you process that if you
do not process something it is like
after picking so what what you don't
process remains order system what you
process is what remain in the system so
an interesting experiment to support
schema theory now the question that we
had at the beginning of this section was
the safe attention is such a hard thing
to look at whether there is something
called automaticity whether there is
something called automatic processes is
there a fact that if attention can
become automatic is there a fact that
can attention become automatic is and if
it becomes automatic with practice can
systems become automatic and pro-human
processing or mental processing become
automatic so that more attention is
available for other jobs now we have
seen that this is possible because the
more learner drivers with a lot of
practice can divert their attention to
multiple other things for example
talking listening to music and so on and
so forth so we look at to that feature
of attention and that feature is that
with a number of practice with a lot of
practice most jobs become automatic in
nature and so attention is freedom the
attentional capacity is freed up so I
will become well practice as we can well
practice doing something that takes less
upper tension to perform a good example
is typing as I said so well you have
been typing on your keyboards for a lot
of time for a lot of years and so you
realize that as you practice as you
learn this type
skilled more and more what really
happens is that things become automatic
it becomes the processing becomes
automatic and so while typing earlier
when you when when you were learning
typing you have to find out where the
cue weit word is where the F and D word
is the switch and all those kind of
things but when as soon as you develop
this habit or style you practiced more
no more tension is available now you can
type talk to people rain coffee and do a
lot of other jobs at hand so basically
typing has become a lot of is a good
example of how automaticity
with practice attention becomes
attentional spans is freed up and jobs
become cognitive George Jacobs automatic
in nature so if one is killed at typing
he can carry out fairly accurate amount
of information and jobs quickly and
carry out a conversation as I just said
so what affects the capacity of any task
at capacity any given task require what
is the reason or what are the factors
which affect the capacity any task is
going to require the answer to the above
question are two factors one is task
difficulty now the more difficult a
toward a task is the more attentional
capacity it will require and the more
time it will require for you to finish
this task so for example if a simple
counting task is given to you a number
counting task is given to you or if a
simple count counting of money is given
to you it's a simple job and doesn't
require too much attention but if I load
your memory with other demands for
example not only the fact that so I give
you a bunch of notes to down let's say
all of them 100 rupees notes and so you
go ahead and count and so if the task
demand is just counting the number of
100 rupee notes it's an easy task but
then suppose I say that this job of
counting the money you have to do till
two things you have to not only it tell
me how many nodes are there but also
tell me which of the nodes are forward
facing and which other nodes are the
worst facing which
I have notes in the bundle which are on
which are forward-facing which has the
front side up or the back side up now
the task becomes a little bit complex
and requires more of attention and
similarly I can ask you several the
other load your memory or working
capacity with several other facts and so
as task capacity increases the task
difficulty increases the capacity
required is more or more more more and
more in demand so the demand of
attention capacity becomes high an
individual's familiarity with the tasks
was the second factor which decides the
capacity any task is going to require is
the individual similarity with the task
now individuals who are very familiar
with a particular task who know what a
task looks like or what is the
requirement of a task they are able to
do a task very nicely and very easily in
comparison to those individuals who do
not know a task for example look at bank
tellers now bank tellers are very
familiar with this counting task they
know how to count and they know a lot of
other things about the counting how the
note looks like what is the crispness of
the note the motor memory which means
the the hand memory of counting is
better and so they can do this job
easily but if you take these people the
same people and into some other job it
is very difficult to them to pay
attention look at coders people like in
our Institute people students who do
coding now when they're doing coding
they are very familiar with the coding
job and it's in a particular language
let's say somebody is learning C is very
familiar with that and coding is easy
for him but he moves from one language
to the other language or tries to do
something else in terms of data mining
or something else in those cases in a in
an unfamiliar territory
it becomes really difficult so
individual similarity how much familiar
you are with a particular task decides
how much
[Music]
effort or how much capacity of attention
you will require and so two important
factors that I discussed now a star's
difficulty and the individual's
familiarity with the task so practice
generally is believed to decrease the
amount of mental effort a task requires
and makes this automatic so as I
discussed briefly with you that the more
amount of practices that you do the more
familiar you get with a particular task
the more easy it becomes for you to do
the task and the more automatic in
becomes the more automatic task becomes
the more our automatic many tasks become
the more easier your life is think of
your daily routine now if your daily
routine if you look into it from getting
up in the morning to come into the to
the mess for having food coming to the
place of study which is the lecture
theatres in our Institute and similarly
and riding a bicycle or based processes
which are there all of these are
automatic right you don't have to put
too much mental concentration into it
you do not have to each day think about
how to ride a bicycle or what should I
do in riding a bicycle or how do I eat
my food you know even a people who walk
here don't even have to think how how
and why my foot is pushing the how do I
walk about pushing the earth down and
that makes me walking they also don't
have to think about simple task of going
brushing or this kind of job these are
fairly automatic and if you ask these
people these students or what happened
today what kind of food you have most
people don't even realize what kind of
food you have it is an automatic process
yes but then there's with practice now
why has this become automatic is that
they do this routinely they do these
tasks routinely over and over again 365
days a year and so it becomes more and
more automatic water my city actually
states it goes ahead and saves your
mental concentration so you can put this
concentration so that you can put this
attention to other jobs which is of
interest and so you can or other jobs
which is more demanding and you can put
your attention so if students are get
engrossed into basic things like what
food they eat or how the cycle bicycling
works or how do they brush and those
of daily activities they will not be
left with mental consideration to read
to understand lectures to understand
what is happening here and so this
practice making automation is an
important fact remember that as we
practice more and more more of your
attentional system becomes free and
becomes available to put into tasks
which require so a very interesting task
or a very interesting experiment which
goes ahead and proves that autumn acity
or being automatic and doing things with
practice the jobs become automatic or as
you practice more and more a task more
and more more attentional system or more
attentional resources are available and
this availability of more resources
makes makes you focus on to other jobs
so which basically means that number
practice you do the more automaticity
becomes and more attentional resources
are available and so a task which was
defined which is called the Stroop task
not just a very very interesting task so
let's do this task and see how does it
really work and in the later half and in
the end of this task I'll also go ahead
and show you the meaning of how this
test really works so Jonas readily
Stroop in 1935 made a famous
demonstration to prove that autumn SAT
is basically the reason or it's it's a
by-product of practice and automaticity
frees up a lot of attention so let's do
the task I'll give you some couple of
minutes to go ahead and do the task so
basically focus on to your screen and
start doing what I am asking you to do
so this is a demonstration of others to
task so look at this demonstration what
you have to do is state the color as
fast as possible so I'll give you one
minute to basically do this task self
task of this and look at this three rows
and quickly name this color or quickly
go ahead and
name this color and write it if possible
somewhere so look at this demonstration
and name the color now I'm pretty sure
most of you would have accurately named
the color bars which are presented here
and so we move to the next part of this
demonstration but I will give you around
about 30 seconds to 45 seconds to finish
this task so in the demonstration to
what you really have to do is state the
colors as fast as you can just read what
is the colors which is we're reading
written on this demonstration just go
ahead and read the colors so do that and
I'll give you 30 seconds for doing it
okay so I given enough time to read the
colors and now we'll shift to third
demonstration but over the advice in the
third demonstration you have to do the
thing that I'm asking you to do as fast
as possible so don't cheat basically
what you need to do is to take enough as
fast as possible the job which is being
given to you and so what you have to do
in the third demonstration is to name
listen very carefully to name the color
of the ink color of the ink in which the
particular word is written so all you
have to do is to go ahead and name the
color of the ink they linked the color
of the ink in which it is written so
I'll present to you and I'll give you a
30 second period to do as this job so
let's turn up do it what you have to do
is to name the color of the ink in which
state the colors of the ink in which
this was a pigment so let's start so
host of you would have completed and did
you see what happened what really
happened is most people actually are not
able to correctly identify the color of
the ink in which this particular word is
written the reason is that red is it and
in green as most people tend to read red
instead of green which is what the
correct
servers are for example here you see
that blue is written in yellow so when
given a task of reading as fast as
possible what you see you will read blue
here but not the question was the thing
that I asked you to do was to name the
color of the ink so your response here
should have been yellow and similarly
here the response should have been red
not green and in this case the response
should be blue not yellow now why does
this happen why is it difficult for you
to to name the color of the ink and
instead of which you can very fast tell
me what the what the display what are
the things are written or the what are
the words written in the display what do
you think happened what is the reason
why this happened and another question
is given enough practice can people
lower the time of response here so if
enough time is given can people do this
task fast so let's find the answer
now stoops task presents with a series
of color bar as i said red blue green or
color word went in on conflicting colors
and people have to name the color of the
ink but then as I said most people are
not able to perform the Stroop task
according to its true why this happened
is that adults are literate participants
has so much practice reading the task
requires the attend that the task
requires little attention is performed
rapidly now since as illiterates
we are so familiar so familiar with
reading we have so much practice with
reading that it is difficult not to read
and so when the question asks is to read
to basically name the color of the ink
it becomes a difficult job why does it
become a difficult job it becomes a
difficult job because reading is natural
to us it's something which we know and
so the first response our system so we
have so much practice with it when the
first response our cognitive system does
is read the letters and that is why you
cannot name the color of the ink but
then what really happens is that with
practice this could be reduced so if I
give this task to you let's say
for five days and if you practice 20
times on five days amount of time it
takes for you to read the color of the
ink it comes easy and so does this
become this conference with the item
consisting of word pairs and now this
type of response when they take little
attention and effort is called automatic
and so on a funny cartoon on the right
hand side you can see that our way
obviously dogs don't see it but then
this puppy is saying to the other puppy
let's see for some reasons human find
this stroke starts really tricky they do
not believe their eyes they don't
believe that humans are so stupid
because you know job dogs cannot talk
and so when dogs cannot talk it's very
easy for them also people who are not
literate people who have very literacy
or less less literacy are not familiar
with the learning paradigm it is very
easy for them to do this job only for
people who are literate people who have
enough literacy or people who have
enough practice with reading it becomes
difficult for them now an interesting
thing that I want to bring in here is
whether the neural structure responds to
attention so whether there are something
called neuro physiological evidences of
attention so basically what I mean here
is that in the beginning of this lecture
I told you I said to you that we were
looking at not only how the cognitive
processes work or what is the reason of
how the mind works I will also look at
something called the brain responses to
it so in the earlier experiments in the
earlier part of this chapter we have
looked at that attended years produce
things from attended years are processed
more than from the unattended year so an
ancient materials or stimuli from the
unattended here is either tuned down or
not processed at all or not picked up at
all and the several theories which go
ahead and say that attended years differ
from an idea in terms of how much is
process so what we want to see is
whether there
is an ERP marker very there is a brain
response to this whether this is true at
the level of the brain and so someone
called banished banished I'm sorry in
1997 he studied or he designed an
experiment to study how does the ERP
markers of the attended and unattended
years in Cherry's experiment I would say
modified Chinese experiment really
evolved so his task was like this there
is this two-year headphone that we talk
about and so both the headphones
actually go ahead the right the the left
headphone and the right headphone they
hear soft and heart tones short and long
tones long and short tones on both the
years so I have long tones and short
tones which shall be presented in both
the year and what people have to do is
to shadow one of the year in this case
the left here and to tell me aloud how
many short tones or long tones rugby was
being presented and the design of the
experiment generally most designs of
fear if experiment in works in this way
so basically this is the time axis and
this is the voltage axis the current
axis of how much potential is generated
what is the amplitude of the ERP ways or
what is the amplitude of the event
related potential wave so basically we
discussed in the first section the TRP
is a method of doing a cognitive
psychology and yet people measures
through sensors on the on the surface of
the head what kind of electric potential
is generated and so after stimulus
presentation so let's say that this is T
equals to zero where the stimulus is
presented from here on 1,000 millisecond
event or 1000 milliseconds section was
cut so eg G's
recorded from different regions of the
brain this eg that I'm talking about is
from the auditory cortex since it's the
auditory job and so this our number of
trials so er P is what you have to do is
you have to take a large number of
trials and basically go ahead and
calculate something called the mean of
all these trials so a large number of
trials are taken and I mixed together
because human beings respond in
different way there is a baseline risk
there is a baseline waveform which is
there and so these baseline bombs may
have may differ so to find out that
unique signature that we are looking for
in erp we have to take a number of
trials so number of trials were taken
and from these number of trials ERP was
cut from the moment the stimulus was
initiated to one hundred to a thousand
milliseconds or a response to thousands
a millisecond was the response time
which was given so within thousand
millisecond you have to go ahead and
response whether it was a short Tolan
long tone and what really happened so
when it was done it was found that an
ERP like this was generated no this ERP
here is something called the N 1 and
this ERP here is something called the P
1 now what is the N 1 and P 1 N 1 is 100
milliseconds so that you see that the
the potential this is the voltage axis
and this is the time axis so what really
happens is that you see a peak a peak in
voltage on the negative side amazingly
most ERP that are in this way so the
upside is generally negative and the
bottom side is not generally positive
off of my graph and so what happens here
is that attended years so this is the
ERP affair attended here this is the ERP
of it unattended here so the one which
is thick is the ERP of an unattended
year and so what is found is that in the
attended year 80 milliseconds so this is
basically hundred millisecond but 80
milliseconds following the the onset of
the stimulus I see a peak and this peak
is called the n1p
this happens this n1 peak is basically a
peak which shows novelty it's basically
a peak which shows new new things into
the stimulus or it's it's basically our
attentional peak most books we'll talk
about this that attentional peak
something which captures the attention
something which is not present in in the
system so basically this 80 millisecond
is a time which is required for a
stimulus to basically come in and
imprint on your or a sense organ so when
you're attended year is waiting or when
they attended here is actually preparing
itself within the first 80 millisecond
of peacfully will register a peak will
be registered and this peak will
demonstrate that it is attend that ended
year the year which is being attended to
shows a brain response or shows our
brain dynamics and this says that it is
attended whereas on the other end here
you do not see this peak similarly you
will find B 1 PP 3 peak and so on and so
forth
but we'll discuss those Peaks somewhere
else at some other point of time when we
were looking at what are our P's and our
ERP is done so in the next coming
lecture upcoming lecture we will
continue with the autumn a CT the
concept of autumn a CT of how autumn SAT
really works what are the factors which
makes attentional systems available and
jobs automatic and how is attention of
capacity allocated you to different
resources and we'll also talk about
something called the psychological
refractory period which is a very
interesting thing to look at thank you
[Music]
you